PROFESSOR: Trees are about
the most basic data structure
that you're ever
going to come across.
They pervade computer
science and other subjects.
So let's talk about them.
And the simplest
definition of a tree
is that a tree is a connected
graph with no cycles.
In this setting we're talking
about simple graphs, and trees
with undirected edges.
Well, in order to
make sense of that,
we better have a
definition of a cycle.
There's a picture
of a typical tree,
but to be precise, what's
a cycle in a simple graph?
Well, it's a closed walk
of length greater than 2
that doesn't cross itself.
So the not crossing itself
is the standard definition
of a cycle that we were
using in a directed graph.
It simply means that it's a
path, except that the beginning
and end vertex are the same.
So it looks like you
start someplace at v,
and then you go
around to a and to w,
and it's all distinct vertices
as you go around in this path.
Except that the
path ends where it
starts at v, which is what
keeps it from being a path
and makes it a cycle.
Now, the length
greater than 2 is
what is the difference between
the definition of cycle
[? between ?] simple
graphs and directed graphs.
And in a directed graph,
it's perfectly possible
to have a self-loop
of length, 1,
that is an interesting and
important kind of cycle
to have.
But we forbid them
in simple graphs,
because there's no way to avoid
having a cycle of length 2,
because you always
have the ability
to go back and forth across an
edge-- that's not interesting.
And so we don't consider
that to be a cycle.
A cycle, then, has to be
of length greater than 2.
It also rules out the
cycle of length 0,
which you get by taking
a vertex all by itself.
OK, with that
technical definition,
we now know what a cycle
is in the simple graph,
and we understand the
definition of tree.
Here are some more
pictures of trees--
simple graphs with no cycles.
Now, they really
come up all the time.
And why is that?
Well, there are
family trees, which
you may be familiar
with-- where you're
drawing a picture of the
descendants of a given person,
and they keep branching
out in a tree structure,
as traditionally displayed.
There are search trees,
which come up all the time
in computer science, where
you branch on the answer
to some question, which tells
you which way to search next.
There are game trees,
which we've already
discussed in this
class, which are used
to define games and strategies.
There are parse trees, that
come up in compiler technology,
and in language theory.
And there are spanning
trees, which we're going
to be talking about some today.
Now, in addition to these
places where trees come up,
there are a lot of
different kinds of trees.
There's rooted trees, where
there's some designated
vertex called the
root, and you think
of getting to all the other
vertices from the root.
There are ordered trees, where
when you're at a given vertex,
there's a distinct
order in which the exit
edges from a vertex-- there's
a first one, and a second one,
and a third one, or a left one,
and a next, left, most, and so
on, so that there is
an order in which you
can choose to leave the vertex.
There are a binary
trees, in which
each vertex has two ways
out exactly-- or no ways out
if it's a so-called leaf.
And then there are a complete
trees, whose definition
is not important to
us, because we're not
going to consider any of these.
There's also, by the way,
directed trees in which edges
have a direction, as in
a [? di-graph ?] tree.
But we're not
considering any of these.
We're going to focus on
so-called pure trees, which
are unordered,
unrooted, undirected,
and that's what
we're talking about.
So let's examine
some more properties
of trees and equivalent
definitions of trees.
It will be important
for theoretical reasons
and convenience to know lots
of different characterizations
of trees.
So we're starting off with
a definition which says,
it's a connected simple
graph with no cycles,
but there's other ways
to characterize it.
So an edge in a simple
graph is called a cut edge,
if, when you remove
it from the graph,
two vertices that
used to be connected--
that is used to have
a path between them--
cease to have a
path between them.
So here's a simple
graph illustration.
And that edge, e, is a cut edge,
because if I delete it, then
there are now two components.
There used to be two
vertices-- actually any
of the vertices here
used to be connected
to any of the vertices
there via that edge.
But once I've deleted
that edge, all of those
vertices here and there that
used to be connected no longer
are.
So that makes e a cut edge.
f is not a cut edge.
Because even if
I delete f, there
is, in fact, still a
path from every vertex
to every other vertex
here, so that f is not
disconnecting anything.
And as I say, it's still
connected after you delete it.
So now we get a simple
way to characterize trees
in terms of cut edges-- because
an edge is not a cut edge if
and only if it's on a cycle.
If you think about that,
if it's on a cycle,
and you cut an edge
out of a cycle,
then everything on
the cycle is still
connected by going the other
way around the cycle that
doesn't use that edge.
And if it's not on a
cycle, then, in fact,
you can think through
that deleting it
means that there's not going
to be two paths between two
things at its endpoints.
And so it will separate them.
OK, so another way,
then, to define
a tree is to say a tree
is a connected graph where
every edge is a
cut edge-- that is
as soon as you cut
any edge out of a tree
it stops being connected.
That yields another way
to say that something
is a tree-- a tree is a
simple graph that is connected
and is edge-minimal,
which, again,
means that if you
remove any edge,
it stops having that
property of being connected.
So its an edge-minimal
connected graph.
That's kind of the reason
why trees are so important,
because if you're trying
to figure out a way
to get a whole bunch of things--
a whole bunch of vertices--
connected, a tree
is going to have
the minimum number of edges that
are sufficient to get them all
connected.
If you think about different
nodes in a network that
need to communicate
with each other,
and you want to know how many
direct connections that there
have to be between
these communication
centers in order for everybody
to talk to everybody else,
the answer is-- it's got
to be a tree on n vertices.
And a tree on n
vertices is going
to have exactly n minus 1 edges.
So that gives you still
another equivalent definition
of a tree.
A tree is a connected
graph that has n vertices,
and n minus 1 edges.
A kind of dual way
to think about it
is that a tree is an
acyclic graph that
has as many edges
as it possibly could
without having any cycles.
So typically, an acyclic
graph might not be connected,
but as long as
it's not connected,
you can keep adding edges
that will connect things up
without creating cycles.
But the minute
you get a tree, so
that everything is connected,
you can't add another edge.
So an edge maximal acyclic
graph is still another way
to characterize trees.
And maybe the most
useful way is to say
that a graph, in which there is
a unique path between any two
vertices, is a tree.
So of course, if there is a
unique path-- in particular,
there's a path, so all the
vertices have to be connected.
But what makes it a tree is that
there aren't two different ways
to connect between two vertices,
because as soon as there
were there would be a cycle.
And those are some of
the basic ways that trees
can be formulated equivalently.
And in fact, there's lots more,
but this is enough for today.